[Music]
I'm sure you have someone that has
cancer and you have seen that person
going through chemotherapy it's often or
hopefully you haven't seen yet people
suffering off Alzheimer Parkinson
Heights there's plenty of problems I
thought problems affecting the human
health now technology has a power to
change this
we're getting a lot of activity and that
is people dying for intervention at the
hospital then for cancer can imagine so
it really needs to do something they are
not effectively imagine that we can
divide one meter in 1 billion part one
of this part is a nanometer
nanotechnology is the science study the
material there are few nanometers for
example viruses are hundred nanometers
DNA 2 nanometers and atoms are like 1.1
nanometers so for example you can see
your hair okay these guys 80,000
nanometers nanotechnology not only
allowed us to visualize a small things
but actually to create things we can
create nanomaterials from bigger
structures or by putting atom by atoms
together so one of the things that I
have in the lab is these nanoparticles
of metal nanoparticles okay so these
metal nanoparticles are kills the
bacteria okay in a very very efficient
way so imagine that you can have these
nanoparticles in a surface in all the
air conditions for exact
okay but think about it not everything
has to be internal we don't have to
always take things how many times you
fly in a plane and you get sick because
one person is sick all the time
so imagine that you have these
nanoparticles all around the air
purification system so every time that
something goes with a bacteria or virus
get in contact with these nanoparticles
metallic nanoparticles it will explode
so it will it will be there but it would
be no toxic we will not infect other
people this nanoparticle kill bacteria
very effectively so what we have here is
a new generation of antibiotics an
antibiotic that is metallic and because
it's metallic it will never confirm a
system but tevia will never be resistant
to this antibiotic
I'm thinking to actually apply on planes
obviously but more important at
hospitals
[Music]
however I still don't know if the human
body will accept so we're trying to make
something different change the way of
thinking what is an antibiotic I'd love
to know how nanotechnologists feel about
the persistent and systemic toxicity
questions that are constantly raised in
what stuttering that we have is that the
risk on nanotechnology is really high
right now so we have a strong revelation
all the things that we can or we cannot
do and this makes a big change
completely and it's based by my pure
English when I don't understand things
about politics something that I'm not my
amateur because I don't know so that's
why we have to do is to teach to
relegate our society to believe that
nanotech is not that part is not that
scary it actually has an incredible good
potential and it's in our hands to
determine the direction of our problems
so I need people to understand what I'm
doing because that's why I'm trying to
do to break the monster behind the
nanotech war you know
[Music]